I will be free.
I will be back, but I should be okay.
Okay, okay. Maybe just a quick call up just to find the specification and stuff.
To structure other lines, map product, the inventory, ambiguity, generate, speed, disruptions, confirmation, trading, response.
Transcript.
You just want to dig on Kennedy, I think.
It should be enough to visualize the...
I mean, it's a accurate and very simplified version of what we went through with Mobin.
Yeah, so I guess the...
What I want to know is, if...
Like, what is the complexity?
And like, what do you really want?
Because if you want to do a small slice, right, it's quite simple.
If you want to do like a whole zheng ERP system, right, that's a different story.
No, I don't think we'll be getting an ERP system for this.
Because we'll be using our ERP system for a very long time, really.
So everyone got you very used to this.
I mean, I'm not saying that it shouldn't change.
It should change.
But I think it should be a ramp up from stage one.
So instead of telling you what I need, right, I think you captured my pain points for the whole thing,
which is that it is very time consuming, very tedious, very manual to think all this right now.
So human, human reliance, prone to error and things like that, standard thing.
So I want to make things easier for the night shift.
I'm not cancelling the night shift job position permanently,
because there are still like hotlines, hardlines, you know, coming through.
But I want to simplify its workflow to make sure that whatever that's been captured and sent by our customers
are accurate enough for the morning ops to draw the inventory.
So that's the number one and most important thing.
That is quite simple, to be honest.
Like, I'm your bro, right? I'm not going to lie to you, right?
It's actually quite simple.
Like, most of it is WhatsApp, right?
That's what, you know what, the handwriting, then tweet.
Luckily, yeah, I can read.
I mean, like, I don't think it is difficult to capture text.
I think it's very difficult to capture, first of all, dialects, you know, accents, different mixture of singlish, you know, that kind of thing.
And oversimplified all this.
Like, I explained to Marvin, for example, you say, hey, I want pork, five kilos.
I want to be very low, okay?
But the pork, just that one more, right?
It can be, like, hundreds of possibilities in our inventory.
So I need to map whatever he says according to his historical data and what's in our system.
That kind of thing.
That is the difficult part.
Okay, so, like, I guess, the dialect part, right, it shouldn't be too hard, okay?
The hard part is, like, verifying against a source of truth to create, like, some sort of rule set.
So that when something comes in, right, you validate whether it hits all the criteria.
So, like, pork, weight, which exact pork, like, you know what I mean, right?
Then the question is, like, where does that source of truth live?
Because you can connect it to, once you have that source of truth somewhere, right?
Once you pull that data into, you know, the LOM brain, right?
Then you can actually validate the incoming with the rules.
Then you say, like, fuck you, insufficient.
I need more information, right?
That's basically the triage that needs to happen, right?
I, let's just do, like, a stupid man job, okay?
I can provide you guys with the, for example, Murphy's ordering items.
One to a hundred, okay?
This is everything he's going to order.
That's everything he's going to need for his daily ops, okay?
I'm able to provide to you the whole list of items that our sales has confirmed with him.
This is all the items that you need.
So when he says something or when he inputs something, it can be matched.
Yeah, and then the idea is that, like, is this a source of truth, right?
Is it Excel, I guess?
Or is it like a random PDF?
Not really important, but I'm just kind of curious.
And how often is it updated?
That's the good question.
So it is being updated in our ERP system.
But our ERP system have a three-month validity of historical orders.
So if you order this thing, like, on the 1st of January and you never order for three months,
so from the 1st of April, it will be, like, pushed down, like, away, pushed away from the order history.
Yeah.
So I can generate, I hope I can.
I'll call the IT site to double-check.
I can generate that for you guys.
But the most stupid way is to actually the product descriptions in the WhatsApp group itself.
The WhatsApp group itself meaning, like…
Like, usually our SOPs, whatever sales close with the customer, right, they will create a WhatsApp group from involving the ops, the finance, the customer, and sales, and blah, blah, blah.
And the sales will actually input all the products, information, and specs inside the group chat description.
So this is to check against…
This is for the night shift guys to check against when they don't know what…
Like, exactly what happened.
Hey, pork.
What pork?
You know, then he will open up the group chat description and say,
Oh, actually, he only…
We order one kind of pork.
Then you just write down that pork.
But slowly and slowly, surely,
He doesn't need that anymore because the moment he sees this customer, he knows already,
Oh, this fucker, only the same thing again.
But he just gonna say pork.
Yup, yup, okay.
So, I guess…
So you have your description written.
The WhatsApp group description doesn't get outdated, ah?
Sometimes I guess you will…
Oh…
Yeah, go ahead.
I mean, they will miss out, but it's the job of sales to keep on updating whenever there are changes.
But usually there won't be significant updates to them.
Oh, I would say 90% of the items.
Only like miscellaneous.
For example, like, oh, I actually have one pork belly, one cm.
But, ah…
Last month I ordered like…
Well, I told you I confirmed like 0.1 cm.
You know that kind of thing.
Okay, okay.
The nuance, ah?
The…
Yeah.
So the pain is…
The…
In the day you don't have problems, ah?
Is it?
Because your staff is on duty, ah?
Is that what I'm hearing?
Yes, correct.
So…
So what I'm…
Why the job gets easier in the daytime?
Because when they are trying…
For example, ah…
Let's say Mervin plays a…
Is a customer, plays an order at the night shift.
He's supposed to order one cm thickness.
Okay.
But, ah…
The night shift just wrote 0.1.
Okay.
So, in the daytime, I mean, when I'm keying in the order into my ERP system to generate an invoice,
I was like, hey, cannot be.
He has been ordering…
The correct one, but he's now saying that he needs a 0.1.
So, I will manual correct, or I will go and check with the customer.
Hey, you yesterday ordered 0.1, is it?
But you are actually…
What you've been ordering for months, ah?
It's 1 cm.
That kind of thing.
So, this mistake goes away with the double authentication.
With your staff, lah?
Yes.
And all the…
All the history.
When they check, hey, the order history don't have, you know, this spec.
So, they will check.
They will message, they will call.
Okay, okay.
So, I mean, the…
The only…
The thing that it hinges on, right?
Is your ERP is built by who?
I know you use some dev shop in India, right?
That's what I last remember.
Yup.
Then, there's the ERP API.
No, right?
It's a…
I guess you can only export, right?
Uh…
I…
A…
Think can export.
But because…
Oh, yeah.
One of the thing is that, you know, this kind of, like…
They show in India.
When you are adding something to the system built by them, right?
It's easy.
Because they…
They want to earn that money, man.
So, when you…
Get a third party to try to add something to…
What they have done, and they are not earning the money, they create a lot of problems.
For…
For everyone.
He, this cannot, that cannot, wrong data, you know, push wrong, pull wrong, you know, that…
That kind of shit.
So, we tried a few times, then…
All failed because of this.
Yeah, yeah.
Makes sense.
So, actually…
Cooling data shouldn't be an issue.
Yeah, but you want to take the stupidest version, right?
That will solve your problem, right?
Is that, you just export whatever.
Like, you SKU lists, right?
And then, uh…
Like, if you can export the order history of the customer, it would be even better,
but I guess it's optional.
Then you just match that with the WhatsApp order that comes in, right?
And then, if you can have the order history exported as well, you just match that with…
And then flag any discrepancy and say like, okay, how come most of the time it's like this,
then now this is different.
Then you just flag it as like, oh, you should probably look out for this because it's…
Firstly, uh, doesn't fit any of the SKUs that we have listed, and secondly, or it doesn't
fit the pass order experience that we had with this client.
Then your day shift will just come in and report saying like, okay, fuck, WhatsApp came
in last night, but we flagged these two things and then can you go chase?
But the rest of it should be, if it's all clear, right, it can be a straight-through pass
la.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
That can be one of the…
I mean, that's the ideal situation.
So, I'm not sure how physical is this, but maybe you can request for like, weekly pooling
of data from my current ERP system to sync with whatever that you guys are doing, the
order histories.
So, I don't need to be like daily update because I don't know how strenuous it is on the cloud
and servers and things like that.
But, I think weekly or something like that, once in a fortnight, pooling data just to
double, just to update, would be nice also.
Yeah, and there are two ways to do it, right?
One is like, you can do the dummy way, right?
Which is that if your ERP has a big export button, which is export everything, and you
just store everything in like, literally a container in the cloud, right?
And then I can just pull from there, and then once you export again, then you override that
one, you know what I mean?
That's the manual way, right?
But if you want to get fancy, you can do automatic pull, but I don't think it's necessary.
If you're saying weekly basis, then it's, you know what I mean?
You just click one button once a week, then everything comes out, and just pull from there.
You know what I mean?
That's like the real MVP sort of…
Yeah.
Then it's not that deep, you know what I mean?
Then you actually, what you really need to solve is the WhatsApp automation layer.
How about this way?
When you guys are building or designing this, give me like, like access to modify the order
history within your app itself.
So that for example, if this, suddenly I need, I don't know if I need, I need donkey, okay?
I need donkey meat today and see something new.
But when they try to order today, they won't be able to see from the order history because
that will be the first time that they are doing that.
So when this kind of thing happened, I can only imagine is that, okay, I will let my guys, okay,
can you go to whatever that you guys are building, just input donkey, you know, as create like a,
like a pseudo order history like that so that it's able to capture.
Yeah.
Why would donkey come up?
I mean, we brought in new products, okay?
First wave, like the, like the pig's blood, okay?
It just came to Singapore literally just weeks.
So a lot of customers are new to this.
They are starting their first order as pig's blood, new.
Then when they order and they didn't sink in time with my ERP system or whichever cloud,
then it creates a big jam, right?
I suppose.
But these are exceptions, right?
These are not the rule, right?
They're not going to be super frequent, right?
Yeah.
I mean, with a daily order of 200 something, I'm not sure how many new items are being discussed
every day, you know, that's the thing.
Yeah, yeah.
So the, the, I mean, the way you can think of it, right, is that you, what you want to do
is first cut all the bulk volume first.
You don't want a perfect solution, right?
You cut the 250 standard things first.
Then you show the 50 things.
I don't know what the ratio is, right?
And say like, okay, for now we'll do a manual.
I mean, you still need some guy in the morning to check it, right?
You still have someone doing the night shift.
You say you're not going to fire the guy, right?
So the guy can handle the exceptions, but at least he knows like the bulk stuff is being
cleared, right?
And then the, the exceptions can be cleared manually, right?
Then that's the, that's the V1, the, the bare minimum.
Then actually that's the most lift.
You'll solve a lot of pain with that, right?
Then you can slowly turn the system to sort of, you know, take the exceptions and start solving
them one by one, right?
And then there's more work.
But if you want to do like, let's say you want to solve the problem today, it's not that
hard, right?
And I think why I always think, yeah, just solve the big problem first, then you just
follow the stuff.
You can just clear up after that, right?
One by one.
You know what I mean, right?
Yeah.
And I guess like the big problem is really that you have how many WhatsApp groups?
Like 200, 300?
Like thousands.
Huh?
Say again?
Thousands.
Thousands, right?
Yeah.
So the hard part is actually tracking the thousands of WhatsApp and figuring out like what the hell
is coming in every night, making sure that everything is like, like the stuff that is easily
solved is solved, right?
Then I think 80% of your pain will go away.
No?
Yes.
So I think what I can try to map out on my end is actually the export API from my current
ERP system.
So I'll generate, I'll ask the team to try to generate customer names with address with order
history.
Yeah.
That'll be perfect.
Then SKU list, right?
Yeah.
Pack them together.
You pack them together into one single source of truth, right?
And this can be synced weekly for now, right?
We can always move it to daily in future because if your dev shop in India is like anywhere close
to being competent, right?
They can get this done in five minutes, I think.
But let's just do weekly first because like don't talk to them, right?
You really know how it's going to go, right?
You do that weekly.
Once you have that, then what I can do for you is your thousand WhatsApp groups, everything,
whenever the message comes in, right?
You automatically cross references that source of truth, right?
And it comes up with a preliminary answer, which says that, okay, based on the rules that you
say, this order is missing information or it is fucking an exception.
It's not in the sink right now, in the source of truth, right?
But these two things will reflect for either the person, you can also automate the back
and forth, but for now it will reflect to a person and the person will just go to the
guy and say, hey, bro, you're already missing something, bro.
You're already missing something, bro.
You're already missing something, right?
You're missing something, right?
And with an exception, then the person will just take over and check the ERP manually and
say like, okay, actually, we actually do have this order.
Does it make sense?
Then the bulk cases will be cleared and your team should be quite happy with that.
That's usually how it goes with, I mean, I've done this a few times already, but you
don't try to solve the whole thing at once, you know?
You kill yourself off.
Yeah.
So actually from the WhatsApp side of things, right, it's quite straightforward.
I know how to do it, right?
And then if you sync everything into an Excel for now, right, it's actually probably good
enough.
You don't need to build a fancy dashboard.
I mean, you can, but I don't think it's necessary.
Just put it in an Excel nicely, right?
Everyday you get one sheet, right?
And the sheet will be color coded with like, okay, this is fucked up.
This is not fucked up.
Can't really.
That's one thing, right?
Then it's printable.
Second.
So I do have some requirements on the format.
First of all, it needs to be a printable thing.
All right.
So because after it's being segregated into different routes and things like that, right,
they need to print this shit out and hand over to the inventory team for them to draw
according to the list, according to the sequence of the jobs.
Okay.
This is point number one.
Second, there are certain format I want it to be printed.
For example, like how much space actually you should leave behind every line.
What's the spacing on all these items?
They're very miscellaneous, small, small things, but this is something that actually
is quite important and critical in my operation.
Okay.
This one, 100% can be done.
All I need, okay, what format is it?
PDF or is it a, what do you normally print?
I need a Word Dog.
PDF.
PDF would be okay.
Yup.
And then all the exact specifications, the minutiae, right, can be done because like,
you can think of it as like, when you use a computer to do it, everything becomes guaranteed
formatting, right?
You know, human beings make mistakes formatting, right?
Computers don't, because it's rule-based.
You know what I mean?
You write a script and the script will always put it in this format, right?
So the key part here is like, firstly, you need to show me one example, right?
Then I will infer all the formatting that you want and I confirm with you.
And after that, you should always be shut out in the same way every single time in any format
you want.
Because turning Excel into anything is a trivial task, but let's put it this way.
Yeah.
Let me show you something.
Sure.
It should be something like that.
You sign on what?
What's that?
Oh, Tele.
Tele, you say.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no.
But, so how do you normally do this today actually?
That's what I'm curious about.
Because this is actually a prototype from the current, current, current, current, current
IT company.
But we do face a lot of resistance because it's all built in one from ordering all the
way until inventory drawing.
So, but the tricky part is that the customer needs to access to links and passwords and things
like that.
So, a lot of these fuckers are just too lazy to operate on their own.
So, this just dies off.
So, what we are doing now is physical writing.
Like when they take call and take message, they are physically writing items on the list.
Oh, but you, you, the one you sent me is not written, right?
It's printed, right?
This is, this is printed.
This is printed.
Which is the prototype that we are not using.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And why are you not using it?
It's because the...
Because, if you try a...
For example, me and Movin are two different customers.
Each of us will have a different unique link for us to access, to place orders.
They need to go into the link and place orders.
But, they are too lazy to do that.
They just want to send like a voice message to make their job easier and make our job hard.
So, that's the, that's the g's of it.
Okay, voice message also can do actually.
That one is under the...
Anything WhatsApp input, right?
Is solvable basically.
As long as it comes in...
WeChat?
WeChat, I'll log into it.
How, how much of it is WeChat?
About WhatsApp, I know, weChat can be done, but I need to go research.
It's the same idea.
You know what I mean?
You, you get the file format.
I think.
Yeah.
But what's the ratio?
I think I would say like a 50-50 or 60 on WeChat, 40 on WhatsApp.
Okay, now I know WeChat.
WeChat confirm that China API is very good one.
WhatsApp is the one that is normally a headache because they are quite anti-automation.
I don't know if you...
Yeah, anyway.
But long story short, both can be done.
It's not a guarantee you, right?
But then, I guess the idea is that you want this form filled up, just without...
Yes.
But then, but in that case, then do you need the password link or all that crap?
No need, right?
No need, no need, no need, no need.
This one is, is, is, is, it need to be plugged into the phone, right?
Or somehow connected to a phone number that we're using.
Or the number, or whichever WhatsApp WeChat account that we need to be linked up.
So, I don't need the customer to access the system.
It's just like auto-capture and generates on the back end.
That, that should do the job.
Okay, then, then like a super simple flow would just be, WhatsApp comes in, right?
You get shared into an Excel sheet.
Your team approves.
Once they approve, it gets shared into a PDF in this format.
Yeah?
That, that would be the, the most basic, you know, without over-engineering or overthinking it, right?
That would probably solve the problem, right?
Yeah.
Then you would just get a very clean PDF in.
I assume you have a template, right?
Just give me a template, though.
Yeah.
And then some examples.
And then, I think that's the entire scope, right?
Yeah.
Cause, I don't know why I even quote you 100K, right?
But that, that is, dude, this is, this is not like that deep, you know what I mean?
It's, if you solve the problem, it's not that deep.
But if you want to go on to expand beyond this, right?
Then it'll be a lot harder, la.
It doesn't make sense, right?
Yeah, bro, it's not code, la.
Because I think you want to do something fancy.
You want to create a platform, la.
Yeah.
So, I mean, these three things, right?
One, what's that in?
Verify against your source of truth, which is the export on a weekly basis of both the
SKU inventory and the customer history, right?
Excel will flag the things that are exceptions.
So, either missing information from the order that is not matching with the SKU, or weird shit
that comes up that doesn't match with the order history.
And then exceptions, which is your blood meat, or your pig blood, right?
That one will just come up as like, okay, not identified.
Then your team will manually do it.
Then once they clean up in the morning, they will just review the Excel.
Then basically they click a button and then it will shit up the correct invoices and
then you can take it from there.
Right?
The correct PDF.
I think that's the flow, right?
Yes, correct.
Okay.
I think that's the flow, right?
Yes, correct.
Okay.
So if you give me two kilos of donkey, two kilos of horsey, you know, that kind of thing.
Horsey.
Okay.
Then you'll be like, what the fuck is a horsey?
So are you able to give me a prompt back to the customer and say, can you clarify what's
!
That thing that you're asking if it doesn't really understand instead of just capturing
and interpreting it on its own.
Yeah.
So I think two things can add, right?
Which is quite simple.
One is that for every order that is captured, we will include the verbatism.
The verbatim transcript or the, what was said.
You know what I mean?
Next to the Excel sheet, you know, in the Excel sheet, there are columns, right?
We'll put in the order.
Then we'll put in the verbatim so that your team can easily scan and say like, oh, actually,
this was the verbatim, right?
Then we can also put the clarifying prompt next to it so that your team can manually feedback.
You can automate this but like, it's not worth it until you see the volume, I guess.
If there's a lot of errors, then you can start saying like, okay, then we want to make a back and forth automation, right?
But, you know what I mean?
I think it would be better for example, I give you like, for example, I ordered 10 items on the list, right?
Then, all done, okay?
Your system captures everything, register everything linked up with the history and blah, blah, blah.
Send a confirmation response.
This is what you ordered.
Then, that's also doable.
Yeah, that will actually eliminate a lot of the back end issues in the morning as well.
So the customer confirms, confirms, like, okay, you confirm really then, like, don't talk about it when it's wrong.
So I think this will help with the whole flow as well.
So basically like a order place, locks in the sheet, sends confirmation in a nice bullet point saying like, you ordered this, this, this, this, this, right?
And then, yeah, with the correct, with the correct decision from my system.
For example, they just say, POC, I'll say, okay, from, is this, POC automatically generate the confirmation, POC barely wants CM cut.
Okay, something like that.
I see.
Okay, okay.
Then, then the only question is like, do you want your team to review first or do you want to automatically send the confirmation?
That's the, they still need to review.
They still need to review, but they, you need to double confirm with the customer.
So sometimes it's like, oh, no, no, no, no, actually I don't want the 1 CM, I changed my mind.
I need 1.5 today.
You know, that kind of thing.
So, but when they see the confirmation, they actually know what they ordered and what they, whichever they said.
I see, I see.
But like, as in, my point is like, you know, the order comes in, right?
Do you want to automatically immediately confirm or do you want to let your team wake up in the morning, check through, and then send the confirmation message if they approve?
Actually, in my operation, this, the moment they place order and my team checks through is confirmed already.
So the really, really confirmation stage, confirm and nail is when they issue invoice, which is the second step of confirmation.
So the first confirmation, I'll put it as a soft confirmation to the customer that we are, we capture your order as such, but this is not what you'll be getting.
For example, some item may be out of stock.
Some item may be missing.
So it's like an auto confirmation.
So the moment they place, they will get a, this is the order that you confirmed.
My team will let you know.
That is the message that we send, immediately after they send something, the customer order something, right?
Yeah, let them check first.
Got it.
Then your team can look at the spreadsheet in the morning and double confirm.
Yes.
Okay, that's just a straight forward.
Because that one will be no risk, you know what I mean?
Because it's just a...
Yeah.
Yeah, okay, okay, makes sense, makes sense.
So yeah, la.
Fuck la, this is giving me a lot of feedback.
Actually why la, is it, is it so much volume is it, or is it like...
Yeah, the, uh, first of all, training a night shift fucker is not easy.
Because he's not, his only job right is actually the night shift.
I cannot fucking work him 20 hours a day by involving him in the day ops.
So, the knowledge that he has is everything on the freaking small screen.
Okay, whichever customer orders, right?
It's just on the screen, he takes it.
He takes the word for it.
So sometimes it's very, very difficult to educate the night shift guys on what the major changes happen during the day.
You know, then he will copy the wrong thing, he will link to the wrong route, you know.
He will, he will, he will, he will commit a lot of mistakes here and there.
So that's, that's, uh, actually some of the mistakes are very, very difficult to...
And why not?
Yeah.
Okay, okay, no, cool.
Then actually, without curiosity, right?
Night shift is like, what time is what time?
I don't know.
But how come your order is at 3am, huh?
Bro, it's 7 to 4.30am.
The last order that they actually cut off is actually when the drivers and the warehouse teams in the office to draw,
then they will cut off the order from there.
So it's about 4 something.
Because they, they, they get off, the, all the, all the chefs get off work around 12 or 1am, right?
Right?
After the cleanup, then they'll start to send order to, they will check in the fridge or whatever missing,
then order for tomorrow's delivery.
So that's why it's all very, very late.
So actually most of your orders come at night, is what I'm hearing.
Yes, most of the order comes at night.
But the daytime orders also quite a bit, also quite a bit, but it's, I would say like 45% comes in the day.
60% comes in the night.
Oh, okay no la, I was just wondering if it's better actually doing something useful, no?
Cause like, bro, if you tell me like you get 10 orders a night, right?
I tell you, just.
No, I easily put me on the orders, yeah.
Per night, okay la, okay la, then worth solving.
Okay la, okay la, then I think it's worth solving la, I mean,
I mean, the, what I can do for you is like a minimal version.
Cause, I mean, unless, actually how much you willing to pay la, out of curiosity.
I, to be honest, I'm, I'm open for offers la, because this kind of thing, I must match whatever that you guys are giving me as a quotation,
versus, uh, the reality check from the finance side.
So I will try to find a middle ground.
But we are not be, we will not be eligible for any grants la, just, just for your information.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
From all my competitors actually, he did a full scale tech solution for F&B companies all the way until routes and things like that
But it's also subscription basis, it's close to a thousand dollar per, I think 900 something, 900 something per month
So if I want to say this, I would say, let's say 30, 40
That's actually, that's actually what Ivan was trying to do for David
To create a whole system
So for this alone, right, how much are you willing to pay?
What's what I'm trying to figure out?
I'll say, let's cap it in 50
50, yeah, okay, okay, I mean, look, 50 is gonna be extremely high for what I think it should be, right?
I'll definitely touch you less
Yeah, I mean, Seth, I think it's gonna be
I thought to you what the competitor is doing, it's actually quite detailed
It's like a full solution, including inventory management and everything
I told Marvin, the reason why I'm not using them is because I told the
I'm quite close with the owner
I told him that your system, really, if I'm gonna use it, right
It's gonna benefit me tremendously
But you are my competitor
You know, you get access to all my data, all my historical data, all my customer data and everything like that
I don't, I will not be able to sleep well at night if I'm able to, if I use your system
And although they say, oh, PTBA or whatever, but I don't trust that
So that's the only issue
So I would say, if you quit your distribution and food trading business, I'll onboard with you immediately
But it's impossible
Yeah, I think, I think like, this is going to be, like if you want everything on your own like servers, right
It's quite, it's doable, but the only thing you cannot do is subscribe to someone else's platform, which is
I guess where this project comes in, right
Everything will be on your own like, own like hosted AWS instance, right
Yeah
Then you can sleep well at night, though
I think that's the
Unless, unless you tell me that always, why is by, uh, Entropic or Alibaba, you know, that kind of thing
Okay, I'm able to subscribe, fuck it, that is okay, but, eh, not him, no
Okay, then the last thing is, is like, so wait, I tell you first, ah, say real, right
I have time now, but I don't know about time like in two months, right
Are you willing to do it like now-ish?
Like, how, how, what is your procurement process, ah, is it going to be very long, la
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
I put time for you
How about this
Today after this call
You give me
What you need
What you guys will be doing
In a little bit more detail
And also revise your code
Let me know how much it is
I will try to work on it
By this week
Okay, okay, sounds good
The proposal right is that
If let's say you start on the project
Then there's maintenance everything
Then you got no time, right?
Then it's okay, I can get DC deal to do
Maintenance, I'm less worried about that
Because
Yeah, it's a back end work, nothing much
Anyone can do that job, actually
I also don't think there'll be that much maintenance
At least for this scope
You know what I mean
The system should run by itself
After we finish all the iterations
If that makes sense
Unless you change your entire business
Then that's a different story
But it should be
Relatively self-serving
You know what I mean
I don't want to be like
That guy, you know
Who's like fucking three months later
And think break and fuck
Bro, it needs to work la
That's the TRD la
Okay, I think let's do
Go ahead
So I think
I also agree with you that
Maintenance, well actually
I'm not sure how
How regular this is servicing
But
I just want to keep
The first phase of this project
As simple as it is
So that
Like you said
It's more or less automatic on its own
And without much
Too much of processing needed
At the back end
So it doesn't have a lot of cock-ups
Hopefully la
Yeah la
Keep it simple
Keep it light
But make it very useful
And then like
Maintenance
I don't plan to charge you any recurring fee la
Unless you really really really want me to
It should just work
It's a one-off fee
And then it's called a day la
Right
And
Then basically the iteration
Until we call a day
Is unlimited la
Until you feel like
It's like
You know
Right on point with what you're expecting
From your workflow
I think that's kind of like
Normally how I do these kind of things
You know what I mean
So
Fixed fee
Unlimited
Iterations
But
When we cut off
And say like
Okay fuck it
This is working right
Then I don't expect the charge of substitution
Okay
Yeah that's kind of like
What I'm thinking
Because
If I charge subscription
Then
Wow
There's a full ballpark of problems
That come with it
You know what I mean
Which is like
Hey success
I want to upgrade la
Then I'll be fuck you
I mean
If it works well
Of course it will be
I want to upgrade in the future
Correct
Then there will be another scope la
Case by case la
Yeah case by case la
Okay okay cool
So I think that's all I need right
And then I will send you
What I
The requirements that I need
From your side
Which is really mostly the data
I mean
I've been keeping
A transcript la
I'll just send you everything later
Then you pass it back
And then I take a look
After I take a look
I can give you a quote
And then
If it's okay right
Then I can start work like
Basically immediately
Cause I got time
Yeah and you'll be doing me a favor also la
Because I'm damn bored dude
Holy shit
Fuck
I'm applying for a job
But I didn't see you
Fuck
Cause it will take at least like
One two months for me to
Land a good job right
So
Yeah la
Come on and drink la
No choice la
Yeah la
But I mean
Don't wanna drink so much la
So
Do some work la
Okay
Okay okay
We work in the day
And night we come out
Okay okay okay
Okay cool
See you
Alright
Bye
Bye bye